[Musique]
et c'est parti pour l'équipe des casques
deux copains d'enfance qui ne l'ont pas
perdu leur âme d'enfants hop flexion
extension
les voici quelques minutes plus tôt au
stand c'est des airbags les airbags on
s'est dit au cas où en cas de choc
le meilleur c'est s'amuser et puis faire
rigoler tout le monde quoi
plus loin les rasta Rocket de Vendeuvre
villageoisin qui aurait troqué leur
bobsleigh contre une caisse à savon nous
on est quatre couples de copains et en
fait comme mon plombier puis on trouve
que les vieux font jeunes on s'est dit
quand même on va pas se casser et donc
on a demandé à nos gamins s'il voulait
nos ados s'il voulait piloter et là
ouais donc du coup en fait c'est eux qui
court
c'est eux qui pilotent
une douzaine d'équipes sont engagées
dans cette courte plus ou moins probable
sur 250 mètres dans la descente des
Cordeliers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça rapporte de l'ambiance et tout dans
le centre-ville c'est sympa
une fois en bas le plus gros effort
consiste à remonter les engins au point
de départ sous les encouragements des
centaines de spectateurs
et il y a quand même pas mal de
donc ça veut dire la plus rapide gagnera
le classement et la course aussi
folklorique ça ce sera la plus belle
caisse qui gagnera qui gagnera la course
de retour au stand il faut réparer ces
bolides de briques et de broc avons un
nouveau départ
la journée il y a de la mousse